je vais demander à gilles d'aller se
mettre en place pour le défi du toboggan
le toboggan humains dans un instant avec
gilles verdez ça va être fou restez avec
nous gilles va prendre de gros risques à
giuly parce que c'est lui qu'on a
choisis pour le toboggan humain
c'est le plus grand toboggan du monde en
fait on dirait on l'a installé sur le
toit
deux des huit il va dévaler fouet à la
fin il y aura le gâteau c'est lui qui va
nous faire découvrir le gâteau deux des
huit meilleurs gilles verdez je crois
qu'ils feraient gilles verdez mongil ou
ou gille ou est ce qu'il est prêt gilles
verdez oh la la
gilles verdez et sur le toit de 2,8
gilles verdez dans un instant va faire
un saut incroyable super nes gilles à ce
que ça l'art des séries tous les gels et
ce que je vois là c'est le flou total à
angers vous acquitter d'un flic total
gilles jehan venir vous voir dans un
instant d'accord mon fils on va parler
tout rires oui je vais vous détendre
vous inquiétez pas à manger juste avant
de revoir ça est ce que vous vous
rappelez de l'homme canon avec juste on
va revoir chez nous bon je joue cette
force en moi aussi je faisais attention
et vous en verrez chez les gars non
voilà faites ce que vous dites monsieur
tout se passera bien que vous êtes tous
monsieur il est parti est parti de
monsieur alors j'ai londres a allumé la
mèche du cadeau en [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] gillot va allumer la mèche du
calen sayan est allumée gilles vous
allez partir dans un instant bush et du
tout je t'aime tarifs à tous j'avais
beaucoup
google
je crois que c'est grave ce qui est plus
drôle parce que c'est le double saut qui
regardaient le regarder le hockey là là
dans l'instant
il craindrait serait ce que jlm en temps
oui je vous entends cyril oui merci
alors les chirurgies je reviens vers
vous dans un instant d'accord je
voudrais laisser qu'on laisse un peu
gilles s'il vous plaît voilà qui
n'entendent pas voilà tout ça parce
qu'il ya jean luc qui va arriver sur le
plateau qui va nous faire les quatre
tiers est ce que jlm entend maintenant
voilà laissez le tranquille qui tondent
et le bien parce que là il va faire un
saut énorme gilles verdez va faire un
saut énorme
regardez cette photo regarder ce qu'on
va faire gilles dans un instant sur les
courts montre la photo
ouf regardez bien il il va il va faire
mal à un saut sur le ventre comme ceux
ci il va descendre tout l'immeuble 2d
vite c'est un truc fou c'est le plus
grand toboggan du monde
sauf que non mais non et c'est trop bon
sauf que sauf qu'il croit qu'il va faire
le plus grand toboggan de monde c'est
encore un mythe mais en fait ça tue le
foot c'est une photo cc un montage en
fait non il n'existe pas le plus grand
événement
la mère du héros revanche est ce qu'on à
la photo du plus petit toboggan et la
photo s'il vous plaît
moreno mission comme ça ça va être
encore une séquence
je crois qu'à ta ta ta rien contre elle
à ces cancers
pas compris tout à l'heure elle me dit
mais je les fais ça c'est terrible et
échos
la bâtisse est là dit elle aimerait
faire
oui d'accord moi je jouais les deux et
c'est pas qui croire mais bon ça va
sinon oh là là mais c'est lui qui a pas
compris changer les piles de
sonn'automne souple et les deux gars y
aura bien des piles si les petites
routes comme ça d'accord allons
d'accueil jean luc lemoine
sam embauchés notamment j'aime ça
bush c
aujourd'hui oui c'était bien je compte
on part avoir participé mois jean luc
houde année nous faire des cafetières
des cartes hier très spécial sur tout ce
qui s'est passé là décident et qui sait
que bin et dire que des néo décès depuis
la rentrée
et puis il va pleuvoir alors quoi
à l'autoriser gilles d'origine va le
voir parce que gilles on va s'en occuper
dans l'instant juste le temps de revoir
ya une séquence qui nous avait fait
beaucoup rire et c'est vrai qu'il n'aura
vous l'avez fait c'est le ice boulette
chalard est-ce que vous rappeler de ça
vous aimez des boulettes j'en peux plus
de tata côté oui bah oui bah merci c'est
bon merci regardez mais la catapulte non
yahia l'autre collège paul valéry lalime
qui leur met vraiment baume au coeur
chalon faire attention à ce qu'on
bientôt
commentant ne le savent pas note 3
c'est dans la douleur
voilà
12 cas d'amputation
exceptionnel
là
cependant l'accord donc des cafetières
des capitiens crabes les captures ce
sera juste après gilles blaquière joly à
du gros dos non il ya du gros dos potion
tout le monde on a besoin de dire
surtout besoin de mathieu pas d'accord
mathieu et c'est vrai que ce soir en
plus c'était une belle soirée pour lui
jules est ce que tu m'as pas mon chéri
oui ouistes en ciel gilles vous allez
faire un des plus grands sauts au monde
mon chéri vous êtes aéromobile ils m'ont
dit que j'avais un masque parce que les
dernières personnes qui avaient tenté ça
avait vu ce qu'il fallait faire avait
renoncé en cours en bas c'est ça non
mais c'est vrai mon chum c'est vrai mais
si vous êtes le plus courageux de la
banque vous le savez mon gillou gillou
mon chéri je vous entends ça va toujours
mieux le sel
gilles avant avant bien sûr de prendre
place sur le toboggan est ce que gilles
mon cher est ce qu'on voulait me dire un
dernier mot ce que voulait dire un
dernier mot aux personnes qui vous sont
chères au 6 juin
vous savez oui un moment comme ça même
de l'ormeau me paraît supportable
et
c'est maxime ce qui se passe ici ces
badges il on va vous mettre en place à
ce qu'on peut mettre en place gilles les
cherry sur le toit des 8
il va faire un saut ne sais plus combien
de mètres 1 c'est vraiment je crois que
c'est combien de mètres le long de
l'autoroute six étages si les tarifs à
tout pour moi parce que si elle n'est
pas là vous l'embrassez pour moi quand
on va voir cela tout bien sûr j'ai une
méthode en place at assurant là là là là
vous me faites peur vous me faites peur
faites attention faites gaffe à lui
énorme attention là prenez pas de
risques les gars prenez pas de risques
les gares les gars fed garde ses pas les
gars mais ne lâchez pas mais les gars
faites gaffe vous savez qui me fait peur
mais moi j'ai peur là arrêtez les gars
vous êtes sûr de vos gars là parce
qu'ils m'ont l'air un peu trop longtemps
la non et même moi parce que j'ai peur
quand même de lever ou non son charrier
parce que j'adore ce qu'ils font là
c'est risqué quand même on sait jamais
si pas légion sur le toile à une font
peur j'ai le mettez vous au plateau mais
taylor en place je veux pas voir ça non
parce que ils sont vraiment sur le tour
il a même été levée mais mettez l'eau
bien en place mais jamais je laisse mon
micro oui là c'est mon micro la chaleur
merci
mettez le en place mais tenant pas se
mettre les gens devant comme si vous
étiez sur l'atome au nord comme si vous
étiez sur un toboggan peut-être
n'avons-nous allongez-vous comme si
l'option est homo n'obtenez bien le
toboggan donc j'ai tellement mais là
comme si mon obsession à tous bords
mettez-vous meinau mettez-vous à plat
votre lave entre autres à plat ventre
oui à plat ventre bah oui c'est comme ça
si l'on évalué risque de se blesser
ego les pardons on peut lui dire un mot
quand même à dieu un dieu gilles taillon
toner attendait une consigne de sécurité
jules ne vous sautez pas laissez vous
glisser
d'accord d'accord basque à 0 pour vous
faire mal et c'est vous utilisez sans la
glisse et lâcher les mâts et les
services et de vous souhaitez pas jetés
par les non je n'ai pas
au bout
oui
j'ai ça va mieux
bravo vous venez nous rejoindre les
cafetières de jean luc rigaut la déchire
est ce qu'on peut voir le show en action
avec le saura que son s'il vous plaît
c'est fou c'est fou
mais qu'est ce numéro un segment